good evening everyone and thank you for
coming thanks for joining us both here
at First Parish Church and online via
the forum network my name is Ashley ten
and on behalf of Harvard Harvard
bookstore I'm honored to introduce
tonight's event with Noam Chomsky
presenting requiem for the American
dream the ten principles of
concentration of wealth and power joined
in conversation by Democracy Now Amy
Goodman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before we begin I want to take a moment
to thank you all for being here your
ticket and book purchases tonight
support Harvard bookstore Harvard
squares landmark independent bookstore
and make this acclaimed author series
possible visit us at Harvard comm to
sign up for our email newsletter and
browser upcoming events calendar
tonight's event is being sewn by
c-span's book TV Democracy Now and the
forum network a joint venture of WGBH
and the Lowell Institute please know
that during Q&A your questions may be
recorded those asking questions at the
end of tonight's event should form a
line at this Center microphone we'll get
to as many questions as we can
after the discussion miss Goodman will
be signing copies of Democracy Now
twenty years covering the movements
changing America new to paperback please
add a respect of those asking questions
and those around you do not begin
forming a signing line until after Q&A
has concluded the signing line tonight
will form in this far aisle to my right
and wrap around the back of the church
anyone joining the line from the center
aisle or the aisle to my left should
head to the back of the church to join
the signing line professor Chomsky is
unable to stay for the book signing
portion of tonight's events thank you
for your understanding to purchase
copies of requiem for the American Dream
and Democracy Now head to the table at
my right after the talk DVD and blu-ray
editions of requiem for the American
Dream documentary film are available for
sale to book table as well as copies of
democracy now as recent interview with
Professor Chomsky you can ask how to get
a free copy of the DVD at the book table
now I'm pleased to introduce tonight's
speakers Noam Chomsky is impute
professor professor emeritus in the
Department of linguistics and philosophy
at Massachusetts Institute of Technology
where he has taught for the past 50
years
his work is widely credited with having
revolutionized the field of modern
linguistics among his widely translated
best-selling political works are his
most recent books what kind of creatures
are we and who rules the world joining
professor Chomsky and conversation
tonight is Amy Goodman the award-winning
and executive producer of Democracy Now
the largest public media collaboration
in the u.s. today they'll be discussing
requiem for the American Dream a series
of interviews with Professor Chomsky
transcribed over four years for a
documentary film by the same name in
these timely interviews Daniel Gould of
the New York Times writes professor
Chomsky focuses on financial inequality
in America and what he calls its
corrosive effects on democracy this is
his first major work on this subject we
really look forward to their discussion
tonight please join me in welcoming Amy
Goodman and Noam Chomsky
[Music]
well no it's wonderful to be together
with you again in order to ensure that
the audience stays to the end do you
think we should save that to what we
practice for the end Guren okay we'll do
that
we're going to get to the book and I
think it's intimately related to so much
of what's happening in this country in
the world today but I wanted to ask you
about this comment that you made that
the Republican Party you said is the
most dangerous organization in world
history
can you explain I also said that it's a
extremely outrageous statement but the
question is whether it's true I mean has
there ever been an organization in human
history that is dedicated with such
commitment to the destruction of
organized human life on earth not that
I'm aware of is the Republican
organization I hesitate to call it a
party committed to that overwhelmingly
there isn't even any question about it
take a look at the last primary campaign
plenty of publicity a very little
comment on the most significant fact
every single candidate either denied
that what is happening is happening
namely serious move towards
environmental catastrophe or there were
a couple of moderates so-called Jeb Bush
who said maybe it's happening we really
don't know but it doesn't matter because
fracking is working fine so we can get
more fossil fuels then there was the guy
who was called the adult in the room
John Kasich the one person who said yes
it's true global warming's going on but
it doesn't matter he's the governor of
Ohio in
ohayo we're going to go on using coal
for energy and we're not going to
apologize for it so that's a hundred
percent commitment to racing towards
disaster then take a look at what's
happened since the November 8th was the
election there was as most of you know
I'm sure a very important conference
underway
in Morocco Marrakech Morocco almost
roughly 200 countries at the United
Nations sponsored a conference which was
the goal of which was to put some
specific commitments into the verbal
agreements that were reached at Paris in
December 2015 the preceding
international conference on global
warming the Paris conference did intend
to reach a verifiable treaty but they
couldn't because of the most dangerous
organization in human history the
Republican Congress would not accept any
commitments so therefore the world was
left with verbal promises but no
commitments
well last November H they were going to
try to carry that forward on November 8
in fact there was a report by the World
Meteorological Organization very dire
analysis of the state of the environment
and the light of likely prospects also
pointed out that we're coming perilously
close to the tipping point where which
was the goal the goal of the Paris
negotiations was to keep things below
that coming very close to it and other
ominous predictions at that point the
conference pretty much stopped because
the news came in about the election and
it turns out that the most powerful
country in human history the richest
most
powerful most influential the leader of
the free world has just decided not only
not to support the efforts but actively
to undermine them so there's the whole
world on one side literally at least
trying to do something or other
not enough maybe although some places
are going pretty far like Denmark a
couple of others on the other side in
splendid isolation is the country led by
the most dangerous organisation in human
history which is saying we're not part
of this in fact we're going to try to
undermine it we're going to maximize the
use of fossil fuels could carry us past
a tipping point
we're not going to provide funding for
as commited in Paris to developing
countries that are trying to do
something about the climate problems
we're going to dismantle regulations
that [ __ ] the impact the devastating
impact of production of carbon dioxide
and in fact other dangerous gases
methane and others okay so the
conference kind of pretty much came to a
halt of the question that continued but
the question was can we salvage
something from this wreckage and pretty
amazingly the countries of the world
were looking for salvation to a
different country China here we have a
world looking for salvation to China of
all places when the United States is the
wrecking machine that's threatening
destruction in with all three branches
of government in the hands of the most
dangerous organization in human history
and I don't have to go through what's
happened since but the in general the
cabinet appointments are designed to
assign to people whose commitment and
beliefs are that it's necessary to
destroy everything in their department
that could be of any use to human beings
and wouldn't just increase profits and
power and they're doing it very
systematically one after another
EPA Environmental Protection Agency has
been very sharply cut actually the main
department that's concerned with
environmental issues is the Department
of Energy which also had very sharp cuts
particularly in the environment related
programs in fact there's even a ban on
posting and publishing information and
material about this and this is not just
at the national level of the Republican
Party whatever you want to call it has
been doing this at every level so in
North Carolina a couple years ago where
the legislature mostly thanks the
gerrymandering is in the hands of the
Republicans there was a study they
called for a study on the effect of
sea-level rise on what sea-level rise
might be on the North Carolina coast and
there was a serious scientific study
which predicted didn't not will forget
how many years not a long time about
roughly a meter rise in sea level which
could be devastating to Eastern North
Carolina and the legislature did react
namely by passing legislation to ban any
actions or even discussion that might
have to do with climate change actually
the best comment of this which I could
quote it verbatim was by Stephen Colbert
and said if you have a serious problem
the way to deal with it is to legislate
that it doesn't exist
problem solved you know
this is this is going on all over the
country and it's not just it's not
simply climate change that's bad enough
but there's another huge specter that
we're kind of trying to survive under
and that's nuclear war and it's a whole
other story here both the Obama
administration and increasingly Trump
are radically increasing that danger
this the threat of the particular of of
the new developments is captured very
effectively in the best simple monitor
of the state of the world established at
the beginning of the nuclear age by The
Bulletin of Atomic Scientists and sure
you all know about this but the bulletin
of Atomic Scientists regularly brings
together a group of scientists political
analysts others very serious people to
try to give some kind of estimate of
what the situation of the world is the
question is how close are we to
termination of the species and they have
a clock Doomsday Clock when it hits
midnight we're finished end of the human
species and much else and the question
every year is how far is the minute-hand
for midnight well in at the beginning in
1947 the beginning of the nuclear age it
was placed at seven minutes to midnight
it's been moving up and back ever since
the closest it's come to midnight was
1953 1953 the United States and Russia
both exploded hydrogen bombs which are
extremely serious threat to survival
intercontinental ballistic missiles were
all being developed this in fact was the
first serious threat to the security of
the United States there's interesting
story behind
little put it aside thus there's time to
talk about it but then that came to two
minutes to midnight and it's been moving
up and back since two years ago 2014 I
think it was the analysts took into
account for the first time something
that had been ignored the fact that the
nuclear age at the beginning of the
nuclear age coincided with the beginning
of a new geological epoch of the
so-called Anthropocene it's been some
debate about the epoch in which human
activity is drastically affecting the
general environment there's been debate
about its inception but the world
geological organization has recently
determined that it's about the same time
as the beginning of the nuclear age so
we're in these two eras in which the
possibility of human survival is very
much at stake and with us everything
else - of course living all living most
living things which are already under
very severe for it well a couple of
years ago I think was 2014 The Bulletin
began to take that into account and
moved the minute hand up to three
minutes to midnight where it remained
last year a couple of about a week into
Trump's term the clock was moved again
to two and a half minutes to midnight
that's the closest it's been since 1953
and that means extermination of the
species is very much in very much an
open question I don't want to say it's
solely the impact of the Republican
Party obviously that's false but they
certainly are in the lead in openly
advocating and working for destruction
of the human species I agree that's a
very outrageous statement
so I therefore simply suggest that you
take a look at the facts and see if it
has any merit or if it just should be
bitterly condemned that's up to you my
view the facts are pretty clear at this
point as president Trump nears is
100-day North Korea and Iran have been a
major focus are you concerned that with
the president at the lowest popularity
rating I think in any president history
at this point that he will focus abroad
as he has in the last few weeks dropping
the Moab the mother of all bombs and
Afghanistan bombing the Syrian
government and yet focusing specifically
on North Korea in Iran and North Korea
McMaster general McMaster the National
Security Advisor saying tensions with
North Korea are coming to a head do you
think there is a possibility that the US
would attack North Korea I mean this
administration is extremely
unpredictable Trump probably has no idea
what he's going to do five minutes from
now so you can literally so you can't
really make predictions with much
confidence but I doubt it very much the
reason is very simple an attack on North
Korea would unleash no matter what
attack it is even a nuclear attack would
unleash massive artillery bombardment of
sold which is biggest city in South
Korea right near the border which would
wipe it out including plenty of American
troops would that doesn't as far I mean
I know technical expert but as far as I
can as I read and can see there's no
defense against that furthermore North
Korea could retaliate against American
bases in the region where there's plenty
of American soldiers and so on
Japan they'd be devastated North Korea
would be finished you know so would much
of the region but they but if attacked
presumably they would respond very
likely in fact the responses might be
automatic McMaster of least and mattis
understand this how much influence they
have we don't know so I think an attack
is unlikely but the real question is is
there waivers of dealing with the
problem there are a lot of proposals
sanctions big new missile defense system
which is a major threat to China
increase tensions there military threats
of various kinds sending an aircraft
carrier the Vinson to North Korea except
by accident it happened to be going in
the opposite direction but will forget
that but these are those are the
proposals that kind of proposals is how
to solve it actually there's one
proposal that's ignored I mean you see a
mention of it now and then it's pretty
simple proposal remember the goal is to
get North Korea to freeze its weapon
systems weapons and missile systems so
one proposal is to accept their offer to
do that it sounds simple they've made a
proposal China and North Korea proposed
to freeze the North Korean missile and
nuclear weapons systems and the us
instantly rejected it and you can't
blame that on Trump Obama did the same
thing a couple of years ago same offer
was presented I think was 2015 the Obama
administration instantly rejected it and
the reason is that it calls for a quid
pro quo it says in return the United
States should put an end to threatening
military maneuvers on North Korea's
borders which happened to include under
trump sending of
nuclear-capable b-52s flying right near
the border
maybe Americans don't remember very well
but North Koreans have a memory of not
too long ago when North Korea was
absolutely flattened literally by
American bombing it was pregnant there
was literally no targets left and I
really urge people who haven't done it
to read the official American military
histories the air quarterly review the
military histories describing this what
they describe it very vividly and
accurately they say there just weren't
any targets left so what do we do well
we decided to attack the bombed a dams
huge dams this major war crime people
were hanged for it at Nuremberg but put
that aside and then comes an ecstatic
gleeful description of the bombing of
the dams and the huge flow of water
which was wiping out valleys and
destroying the rice crop on which Asians
depend for survival lots of racist
common but all with exultation and Glee
you really have to read it to appreciate
it
the North Koreans don't have to bother
reading it they lived it
so when nuclear capable b-52s are flying
on their border along with other
threatening military maneuvers they're
kind of upset about it strange people
and they continue to develop what they
see as a potential deterrent that might
protect the regime from on the contrary
in fact from destruction
this has nothing at all to do with what
you think about the government so maybe
it's the worst government in human
history ok but these are still the facts
that exist so why is the United States
unwilling to accept an agreement which
would
and the immediate threats of destruction
against North Korea and in return freeze
the weapons and missile systems well I
leave that to you and remember that's
bipartisan in this case could
negotiations go the usual argument as
well you can't trust them and so on and
so forth but there is a history and I
the time to run through the history it's
quite interesting begins in 1993 when
Clinton under Clinton of the North
Koreans made a deal with Israel to
terminate North Korean missile shipments
to the Middle East which is a great
serious threat to Israel in the world
and in return Israel would recognize
North Korea the Clinton administration
wouldn't accept that they pressured
Israel which has to do what they're told
to withdraw from it and North Korea
responded by sending by firing their
first intermediate-range missiles I
won't go on with the rest it's a very
interesting story
but there was actually an agreement in
2005 that North Korea would completely
dismantle its nuclear weapons and
missile systems and the finish dismantle
them in return for a non-aggression pact
from the United States an end to threats
provision but by the West that means by
the United States of a a light water
reactor which can produce nuclear
weapons but could produce be used for
peaceful purposes research medical other
purposes that was basically the
agreement 2005 didn't last very long as
the Bush administration instantly
undermined it it dismantled the
consortium that was supposed to provide
the reactor and it immediately imposed
pressured
and when US pressures it means it
happens banks to block North Korean
financial transactions including
perfectly legitimate trade so the crazy
North Korean started producing missiles
and nuclear weapons again and that's
been the kind of record all the way
through so yeah maybe the most horrible
regime in human history but the fact of
the matter is the regime does want to
survive and it even wants to carry out
economic development there's pretty
general agreement about this which it
cannot do at any significant way when
it's pouring resources very scarce
resources into weapons and missile
production so they have considerable
incentive including survival to perhaps
continue this process of reacting in a
kind of tit-for-tat fashion to US
actions when the u.s. lowers tensions
they do when we raise tensions they go
on with these plans how about that as a
possibility I mean it is if you look at
the preston allah mentioned acted was
not a bad article in The Washington Post
about it recently by us professor
teachers in South Korea so occasionally
this strange possibility of letting the
North Koreans do exactly what we want
them to do sometimes this is mentioned
but it's pretty much dismissed we can't
do that sort of thing
there are similar questions to raised
about Iran so we run as you know the
again the adults in the room like mattis
and so on so it's greatest threat to
peace you know greater sponsor of
terrorism on and on how is it a sponsor
of terrorism well could go through that
so for example in Yemen it's claimed
that they are providing some aid to
rebel tribesmen hooda tribesmen in Yemen
okay maybe they are what is the United
States to
yeah it's providing a huge flood of arms
to its Saudi Arabian Ally who are
destroying the country who have created
a huge humanitarian crisis huge numbers
of people killed massive starvation the
threatening out the Obama port which is
the only source of aid for surviving
people but Iran is the major source of
terrorism and if you look around the
world there's many questions like this I
don't want to go on too long but very
strikingly and this there's one lesson
that you discover when you carefully
look at the historical record and what I
just described about North Korea is
pretty typical over and over again there
are possibilities of diplomacy and
negotiation which might not succeed it
can't be sure if you don't try them but
which look pretty promising which are
abandoned
dismissed literally without common in
favor of increased force and violence in
fact that's also the background for the
1953 moment when the clock moved to two
minutes to midnight and the u.s. faced
the first serious threat to its security
that in fact you know since probably the
war of 1812 could have been avoided
there's pretty good evidence that it
could have been avoided but it was the
possibility was literally not even
considered and case after cases like
this it's worth looking at the
historical record from that perspective
to ask whether that general comment has
some validity I think if you do you'll
find that it has considerable merit I
last interviewed you on April 4th just a
few weeks ago on Democracy Now it was
the 50th anniversary of dr. King giving
his be on Vietnam speech why I opposed
the war in Vietnam where he called the
US
the greatest purveyor of violence in the
world and I wanted to turn from North
Korean Iran to Syria it was the day of
the gas attack in Syria so we didn't get
to talk about it very much and I'm
wondering your thoughts on what you
think happened
and then the ensuing u.s. bombing that
president Trump would later talk about
saying he was having chocolate cake with
the Chinese president very very good
chocolate cake and when they launched
the Tomahawk missiles into Iraq he said
and he was corrected by the interviewer
right who said it was actually country
ragheads
so about the same but well there are
some things we know for sure there was a
serious chemical weapons attack nobody
doubts that it's plausible that it was
the Syrian government which does raise
some questions not so obvious why the
Assad regime would have carried out a
chemical warfare attack at a moment when
it's pretty much winning the war and the
worst dangerous phases is that a counter
force will enter to undermine its
progress so it does raise some questions
it also even though maybe the you can
think of some reason why the Assad
regime which is a murderous brutal
regime might have done it
it's there's even another question as to
why the Russians would have allowed it
remember this is a the air base as a
joint Russian Syrian base Russia has
plenty of clout in Syria and for them as
a total disaster they have global
concerns not just local in terms of
Syria so there are some concerns and
there are further concerns there has
been the white house did put out a
careful analogous occation and
intelligence report
to explain an account for showing why
they had absolute confidence there was
Syrian government attack this was
analyzed closely by a very serious and
credible analyst an Theodore postal
president MIT who has a long record of
highly-successful credible analysis as a
highly regarded strategic analyst and
intelligence analyst and he gave a
pretty devastating critique of the White
House report you might you can pick it
up online and take a look at it so there
certainly are some questions that
there's that Syria is capable of a
monstrous act like that the Syrian
government that much is not in doubt but
one question that arises is before doing
something could you find out what
happened okay I mean let's have an
inquiry take a look and see what in fact
actually happened other plenty of cases
where things where look that thing as
though things happen but they didn't I'd
remember that report reporting from
Syria is extremely difficult if
reporters go into the rebel-held areas
and don't do what they're told you know
get your head cut off Patrick over and
others have written about this just
can't seriously report from those areas
there are obvious questions when you're
reporting from the government side so
the recorders are there are very good
reporters doing a serious courageous job
but there's not much you can do so we
just don't know a lot well those are the
circumstances in which the 59 Tomahawk
missiles were launched that's pretty
easy it's easy to sit in Washington and
push a button and say go kill somebody
that's considered courage you know amend
macho showing how strong we are what did
they actually do well apparently the
Tomahawk missiles were targeting a part
of
the airfield that doesn't seem to be
used and in fact the next day at planes
were taken off and affect the village
that was attacked by the chemical
weapons has been even more heavily
attacked by straight bombing from the
Assad government after the 59 Tomahawk
missiles so whatever they were intended
to do it doesn't seem to have anything
to do with Syria I suspect that what
they were intended to do was pretty much
what you described to shore up Trump's
image as I think was nikki Haley at the
UN said there's a new sheriff in town so
now we've got Wyatt ER you know I'm
pulling out his gun and getting rid of
the bad guys no more of this soft stuff
so it was probably an attempt to shore
up that image pretty much like the bomb
in Afghanistan nobody knows what it was
for what it had to do with probably
destroyed a large part of Afghanistan
shortly after that there was a massive
incredibly brutal and successful Taliban
attack which killed a couple hundred
recruits most of them unarmed the young
draftees didn't know what they were
doing the was so bad that the fence
Minister resigned doesn't seems of any
effect on it was supposedly aimed at
Isis maybe it was maybe it wasn't they
don't seem to be affected by it
so these look like that doesn't seem to
be any strategic analysis behind any of
these actions as far as anyone can tell
they seem like kind of about at the
level of the twitters that keep coming
up something that kind of occurs to me
so why not do it it's cheap may kill a
lot of people makes me look good it
makes it seem as if I'm defending the
country and so on it's hard to see it as
anything but then that these things help
the people of Syria and Iraq is very
hard to imagine what do you think has to
be done to solve the crisis the
humanitarian catastrophe
in Syria it's a terrible catastrophe and
you know unfortunately there isn't a lot
that can be done about it there are some
things that can be done I mean the idea
that you can send in the Marines and
bomb and so on that has a small problem
if you do you probably set off a nuclear
war and not only is Syria destroyed the
rest of Syria but the rest of the world
too so there's a little difficulty in
that scenario whatever one thinks about
the justification for it so what can be
done well one thing that can be done
which is really easy very easy is to
take care of the people fleeing from
this disaster are there huge numbers of
people fleeing from the disaster what do
we do about them make sure they don't
come here you know kind of like people
fleeing from my relatives in fact
fleeing trying to flee from Eastern
Europe and under the knots before when
the Nazis were coming along not we don't
want not here you know so the Syrians
don't come maybe a tiny trickle but
where if you come here Europe's not that
much better in fact pretty horrible - so
one thing you could do is just take care
of the people who are fleeing the
disaster another thing you can do is
provide humanitarian aid for those in
the region there are countries who are
absorbing refugees remember like take
Lebanon it's not a rich country like us
poor country about 40 percent of the
population are refugees many of them
fleeing from the Israeli wars far back
is 48 and many a huge number of Syrians
Jordan another core countries absorbed a
huge number of refugees that Turkey has
a couple of million
Iran has
excepted refugees so there are very
there are poor countries that are
accommodating refugees but not the rich
countries the rich countries it's not
our business certainly not us it's even
more serious problem with regard for
with it for us moral problem with regard
to Central America but let's keep the
Syrian so another thing to do is provide
badly needed aid and assistance for
those who have succeeded in fleeing the
disaster or who remain in parts of Syria
where survival as possible but are
living under horrible conditions
that's all cheap and easy frack tiny
fraction of increasing the military
budget to cause more destruction now the
other thing that can be done and is
being done is to try to support local
efforts throughout Syria at local
ceasefires just to lower the level of
violence that's happening in different
places maybe the people don't like each
other but people sometimes like to
survive and there are accommodations
worked out and they could be helped a
broader possibility is to try to pursue
the negotiations that will lead to some
kind of diplomatic settlement now there
have been efforts but they're mixed and
there probably can't be certain but
there seemed to be possibilities that
were meant but dismissed so for example
in 2012 there were reports from former
Finnish minister octa sari as a very
credible record of involvement in
international peacekeeping who claimed
that the one of the Republic that our
Russian diplomat had proposed a
settlement in which Assad would be eased
out in the course of the negotiations
and some settlement would be reached in
which the Assad regime would
the ended that was apparently dismissed
without comment the US and Britain and
France just assumed at that point that
they could overthrow the Assad regime
they didn't want have anything to do
with it that's the report the report
appeared in England as far as I know it
was never in reported here like good
reporters is it true
who knows got to look into it to find
out whether it's true you have to
inquire you have to pursue the options
if they exist and they weren't but there
are things that could be done not what
we would like to see you know it'd be
nice to see here solution will make
everybody happy and in the destruction
but those just don't seem on the on the
possible agenda because for all kind of
reasons including the threat of a very
serious war if Russia and the United
States don't act in a high level of
concert in in pursuing whatever they may
be doing no I wanted to before we get to
your book your latest book ask you about
this latest development in the United
States the director of the Central
Intelligence Agency gave his first major
address and he focused on WikiLeaks and
it looks like now the u.s. is preparing
an arrest warrant for Julian Assange
who's been holed up in the Ecuadorian
Embassy in London for almost five years
now Pompeyo calling WikiLeaks a hostile
non-state intelligence service calling
Julian Assange himself a demon and said
he's not protected by the First
Amendment your thoughts well I think
speaks for itself
WikiLeaks has released lots of
information that governments don't like
it's overwhelmingly information that
citizens should have its information
about what their governments are doing
and perfectly natural that systems of
power don't want to be exposed so
they'll do what they can to prevent
exposure the I think it's a disgraceful
act in fact I think it's disgraceful
even to keep Julian Assange holed up in
the Ecuadorian Embassy he's I did visit
him there once but you can guess
yourself it's in many ways worse than
imprisonment at least if you're in
prison you can see other prisoners and
you can get out and look at the sunshine
now and then he's in a small apartment
where you can't go out you know go to
the balcony but that's about it
the smaller poor basically a couple of
rooms inside a small apartments not a
big embassy the embassy is like a kind
of an apartment in London surrounded by
police and so on
there's been no credible basis for any
of this and to go on to try to Cara to
raise at the level of the criminal
prosecutions I think is again one of
these efforts to look tough at home and
the kind of effort that a government
would carry out that is dedicated to
trying to protect itself from exposure
of facts that citizens should have but
systems of power don't want them to have
I think that's the crucial issue the
suggestions are it has to do with his
aiding and abetting perhaps Chelsea
Manning and also Edward Snowden in doing
that with Edward Snowden which he openly
admits while he's trapped in the
Ecuadorian embassy if if the charge is
true he should be honored for
Chelsea Manning and Edward Snowden or
carried out heroic courageous acts they
fulfilled the responsibilities of
somebody who takes citizenship seriously
that is who believes that the people of
a country ought to know something about
what they're going up to okay like if
their government is carrying out
murderous brutal attacks in Iraq people
should know about it
Texas back to Martin Luther King's talk
in 1967 if the government is and
corporations to incidentally are
listening in to your telephone
conversations and what you're doing you
know tapping this discussion so on we
should know about it governments have no
right to do things like that and people
should know about it and if they think
it's okay fine let them decide not do it
in secret
I think people wouldn't agree to that's
why it's kept a secret why else keep it
secret you know and these are people who
exposed it at great risk to themselves
so those are heroic courageous acts if
WikiLeaks was abetting them more power
to them that's what they should be doing
I mean President Trump endorsed
WikiLeaks right he said I love WikiLeaks
to campaign when it was releasing things
that he liked yeah any system of power
will do that you release information
that I like it's great but I don't want
to be exposed
speaking of entities that President
Trump doesn't like he called the press
the enemy of the American people the
enemy of the people can you assess as
the media assesses President Trump in
his first 100 days the media's behavior
well I think the media has fallen over
backwards to try to give him some
protection and leeway I mean you know
there are things that are so ludicrous
and outrageous that up a reporter simply
can't
keep from saying something about them
like there's one ridiculous claim after
another that comes out of the tweets you
know three million illegal undocumented
refugees voted for Clinton Obama
wiretapped the Trump Tower you know one
after another
my sense is this is just a guess that
this is a media strategy but it's the
Bannen Trump
spicer strategy to try to keep attention
focused on the one or another form of
lunacy but not look at what's actually
happening that what's actually happening
is that Paul Ryan and his associates
behind the scenes are systematically and
carefully dismantling every element of
government that is of any benefit to
people and that doesn't maximize
corporate power and profit I mean the
dedication of the Republican leadership
especially the Ryan type leadership
their dedication to slavish servility to
corporate power and wealth is just
phenomenal I mean read this morning's
business pages their latest step is to
try to prevent exposure of complaints
against banks that carry out improper
activities it is possible now thanks to
consumer protection act for people to
criticize when they think a bank has
carried out some improper activity but
we got to keep that silent you know
because we have to protect corporations
from any exposure of criminal activities
that might carry out I mean down to that
level in fact everywhere you look I mean
the health care proposal was so
shocking that I was a proposal basically
to cut taxes for the rich and to ensure
that poor and middle-class people people
voted for Trump in fact don't get
medical aid as you saw of course
Congressional Budget Office estimated
twenty four million additional people
uninsured it was an analysis of that by
Steffi wool handler David Hamill Stein
to health specialists just studying the
relationship between lack of insurance
and deaths there's plenty of evidence
about that and it turns out that would
have meant about forty five thousand in
additional deaths a year that's okay as
long as you cut taxes for the rich and
step-by-step that's what's happening
behind the facade of Trump isms and you
know Spicer addicts before the press and
the press is pretty much falling for it
that's what they focus on not what's
being carried out there is of course
criticism mild criticism of outrageous
lies but I think that just plays the
game that's what the lies are for then
you can yell about the liberal press
that destroyed undermine us so all the
kind of a desperate effort to keep a con
game going a Trump does have a base
voter base he's kicking them in the face
with abandon and the idea is how do you
hold on to them while you're doing this
not an easy trick and this I think is
part of the con and there are people in
the press who are pointing it out to
Paul Krugman for one but nothing like it
it should be which takes us to your
latest book requiem for the American
dream where you talk about the ten
principles of the concentration of power
and wealth how it's happening what to
watch out for
well credit for the ten principles
should go to the producers of the film
what they did was take a lot of
interviews and discussions about all
sorts of things and put them in a
coherent and I think pretty effective
form including formulating ten
principles that's their contribution and
including material that discusses them
and you can look at the film and see or
the book but my feeling is they did a
really good job so this book is
accompanying this film that is now out
on Netflix but you talk about for
example principle one reducing democracy
principle to shaping ideology and
principle three redesigning the economy
well all of those fall together and
they're part of a pretty remarkable
development that's taking place in
actually in human history humans in the
last 60 or 70 years have succeeded in
creating a kind of a perfect storm
literally - there's a kind of a pincers
movement that we've created two major
attacks on the prospects for survival
global global warming nuclear weapons of
the Anthropocene the nuclear age and the
third is a set of socio-economic
policies designed to undermine the
possibility of dealing with the problems
the problems could be dealt with only in
a functioning democracy of engaged
informed people who could make decisions
who would be informed and could make
decisions to deal with the crisis but
the so called neoliberal programs of the
past generation
sort of somewhat market oriented
programs designed to undermine the
institution's governmental and popular
institutions that might deal with these
issues all a unit one result is a very
significant decline in democracy you can
see it in the it's which is almost built
into the policies it's perfectly built
you can't carry out economic policies of
the type that have been there that have
been implemented in the past generation
in a functioning democracy that's
impossible let me just take a look at
the numbers so the neoliberal programs
were basically taking off right around
1980 escalated started little with the
late Carter as belated under Reagan went
on more under Clinton's on 2007 was the
peak of supposed success this is right
before the crash a lot of euphoria among
economists political analysts about the
great achievements of neoclassical
economics of the Great Moderation
you know the the deal with liberal
programs dismantling of regulations all
these great successes 2007 what was
happening to American working people at
that time in 2007 wages real wages were
lower than they had been in 1979 when
the experiment took off in fact for the
majority of the population it's a period
of stagnation or decline the benefits
have declined people had been some of
the reasons were explained by Alan
Greenspan head of the Federal Reserve
who was charged pretty much of managing
the economy he testified to Congress
that part of the success of the economy
that low inflation Zahn was due to
he called growing worker insecurity
people working people were insecure they
were intimidated they knew they that
they were in a dangerous situation
precarious situation as a result they
didn't press for increase in wages
invent for decent wages and benefits
they were willing to accept effective
effective decline in their living
standards and greenspan who was a close
observer of the economy pointed out that
this continued even when jobs were
increasing in the late clinton period it
was deeply embedded in the nature of the
policies being carried out that working
people are intimidated the living for
Carius lives
many of them are part-time they're
losing security their unions are being
destroyed and their wages are declining
so it's all great the economy is
wonderfully healthy can you carry out
policies like that in a democracy I'm
going to people want to vote for it
salmon Europe even worse in many ways
the so-called austerity programs even
the economists of the International like
the IMF International Monetary Fund
their own economists say report that
these policies make no economic sense
but the IMF bureaucrats the ones who are
part of the decision-making apparatus
they vote for them how do you and the
effect on Europe is the same thing as
far as democracy is concerned just like
in the United States there's anger
contempt for major instance interests
for you know for the major governing
institutions here is Congress there are
some political parties
you just saw in France yesterday the two
major parties were barely visible in the
election and it's happening all over
Europe same kind of thing that's
happening here I mean here it's
happening in a way which is almost
farcical because of the
you know the kind of actions carried out
by the leadership in Europe it's being
it's being pursued in a way which is
really ominous I mean look for back to
find a time when fascist parties
actually had power in Europe and we know
what happened and now there are neo
fascist parties with fascist roots often
which are pretty close to power even in
places like Austria and Germany which
have some memories of France as well was
under the Nazis was extreme very Pro
Nazi country the Vichy government was
rounding up Jews faster than the Germans
one of them really ugly record I'm
seeing these things come back or just
seen a situation in which according to
recent polls a majority of Europeans
think there should be no more Muslims in
Europe I mean that evoked some memories
not nice ones and a lot of you can't
attributed all to the neoliberal
economic policies but a lot of it does
follow from that when you impose on
people circumstances of this kind you
have to make sure that they have no no
way of responding politically in Europe
it's done pretty straightforwardly
the main decisions about socio economic
policies are made by the so-called
troika IMF European Central Bank and the
European Commission which is unelected
so three unelected bodies they make the
decisions they do listen to voices the
voices of the northern banks mostly
German banks and the people suffer and
they act get their angry frightened
often reacting in dangerous ways we see
similar phenomena here so to go back to
the pincers movement what's happened is
we've created
two huge threats to survival we have
systematically not you and me but the
leadership has systematically created
socio-economic policies which have as a
consequence almost immediate consequence
the undermining of functioning democracy
the one thing that might deal with it
disasters like I said it's kind of
perfect storm real credit to the human
species to have contrived something like
this principle four is shift the burden
onto the poor in the middle classes
principle five attacked the Solidarity
of the people six let special interests
run the Gullah regulators seven engineer
election results a use fear and power of
the state to keep the rabble in line
this is necessary to comment I think
you're all nine is manufactured consent
and principle ten is marginalized the
population in fact that's exactly what's
happening and it's the and there's a
reason for it you cannot carry out the
kinds of policies that have been
developed in the last generation and
have the population function
democratically in Europe you can't get
people to vote for policies which are
undermining their lives which are a
limit which are leaving especially the
younger people without any hopes of
decent employment which are driving
people to precarious existences which
are undermining wages reducing benefits
in England right now undermining
threatening what had been the world's
most by far the world's most effective
and efficient national health system you
can't get people to vote for things like
this so what you have to do is
marginalize them in one way or
turn them against each other and turn
their anger against vulnerable people
that's standard technique get people to
don't look at the people who are really
doing this to you
look at the ones who are more vulnerable
immigrants the poor you know Muslims
blacks anybody we're familiar with that
too there's not a slight history about
it so sure that just it's like a it's
like an almost logical consequence of
the socio-economic policies which have
been imposed and lauded in fact by
elites including liberal elites a lot of
this was done but say by the Clinton
administration it was held the
deregulation for example which
immediately very quickly led to one or
after another financial crisis that was
initiated by liberal economists who were
telling us how wonderful it is and
there's actually a you know a theory on
the Oakland neoclassical economic theory
which says yeah it's fine actually there
were people who warned against it there
were people who knew a lot of left
independent economists but even people
right out of the mainstream like Joseph
Stiglitz Nobel laureate back around 1995
or so he wrote an article actually in a
World Bank research journal in which he
warned against what he called the
religion that the market knows best
he says that's the religion as he put it
that's being followed by economists and
he says you got to take a look at that
religion like a lot of religions just
doesn't work
economic history and even logic show us
lots of things that are wrong about it
but that was pursued with abandon on the
basis of theories of the efficient
markets rational behavior rational
expectations and so on none of which had
any
empirical basis our founding but they
worthy the doctrines were accepted for
the very simple reason that they were
highly beneficial to wealth and power
that makes them acceptable and you get
the results that you have the
undermining of the only means possible
to try to deal with the existential
crises that we have created so again
it's a kind of perfect storm part all
sorts of sources including just socio
economic policies of a bipartisan nature
you talk about a perfect storm do you
think fascism is rising in the United
States I think there's a danger of
fascism in Europe but I don't think that
it for one that you have to be a little
bit careful about that I mean if you're
a black kid in the ghetto yeah you can
say kind of looks like fascism but for
most of the country most of us Pete like
people like us there aren't
stormtroopers in the streets
there's no fascist political party
there's no ideology of fascism the Trump
ideology reduces to pretty much me you
know that's
not fascism whatever you think it is so
there's there are serious dangers but
but I think fascism in a way gives it
too much credit it makes it look like
more of a well formulated ideology than
it actually is I think what we're seeing
are the desperate efforts to try to hold
together rising disasters that for which
the means have been undermined in their
resistance from the women's protests
massively larger than president Trump's
inaugural crowd just like day after you
have to look at the tweet to the protest
just this week from the March for
science on Earth Day on Saturday - the
one that's coming up next Saturday April
29th another people's climate March the
March for science took place on every
continent in the world the people's
climate March promises to be much larger
does this give you hope there's a lot of
reasons for hope first of all there is
enormous resistance the kind of thing
that's happened sometimes before like in
the early 80s when there was huge public
opposition enormous public opposition to
the dangerous increase in nuclear
weapons development and it had an effect
like I mentioned that the bull of atomic
scientists a couple years ago Doomsday
Clock went to three minutes to midnight
that's the closest it had been since
1984 when there was a major war threat
with the increase in nuclear weapons
threats and it was significantly
attenuated by popular action and then of
course there was the activism of the 60s
and the 70s it didn't end in the 60s by
any means so some of the most effective
popular movements with the biggest
impact on the society are really
developed in the 70s like the women's
movement
the environmental movement's and so on
the seeds were in the 60s but they
weren't there yet they were just barely
beginning all of that has really
civilized the society had lots of
positive effects and it goes on right to
the present so the most I think the most
significant fact about the last election
was not Trump's victory which was very
serious for the country in the world but
the astonishing success of Bernie
Sanders campaign it's worth remembering
that that broke with over a hundred
years of US political history u.s.
elections are pretty much bought you can
predict with remarkable precision
electoral outcomes by looking at simple
measures like campaign funding is very
serious work on this the main person
many of you know is Tom Ferguson
political scientists at UMass done
really good work on this and it's very
impressive work you can almost predict
the outcome of an electoral campaign
president House said it just by looking
at campaign funding and of course that's
a predictor of policy as well and that's
been well known you know from way back
among people who run campaigns and by
now the evidence is overwhelming so what
it Sanders do had no corporate support
no support from the wealthy no support
from the media which mostly either
dismissed or denigrated him the unknown
person nobody had ever heard of him he
was proposing what about the New Deal
policies by contemporary US standards
that's what he called with some justice
of political revolution actually the
policies he proposed it wouldn't have
surprised Dwight Eisenhower
he favored similar policies by and large
in fact even said that anyone who
doesn't accept New Deal programs just
doesn't belong in our political system
every strong supporter of unions and so
on
we've come quite a ways since then but
Sanders was a voice going back to the
period when there was very rapid growth
the Galit aryan growth the serious
beginnings of an attack on some of the
deep crimes of the country that go way
back like the racist primes and others
then came the 60s the civilizing effect
their consequences then a regression the
regression of the last 30 40 years the
neoliberal programs and all their
consequences and then saying that
without but not ending activism by any
means was plenty of activism and Central
America solidarity movements for example
which was quite effective but Sanders
broke with over a century of history
that's pretty serious and it's having an
effect Fox News informed us should thank
them for that they did a poll of
popularity of political figures how much
do you like various political figures
one person was way in the lead Bernie
Sanders far above anyone else even
higher among young people those are
pretty serious achievements and there's
a lot to build on there and in fact out
of the Sanders popular movement there
are developments growing which I think
are quite constructive and are
coalescing and integrating with many
other things that are happening so there
plenty of grounds for hope but the we
are in an extremely dangerous situation
it's not some of it let me know if
there's a little time just go on with
something that isn't reported as
extremely serious last January
a couple of weeks into the a week or so
into the Trump term the minute hand was
moved to two and a half minutes to
midnight but since then we have learned
things which I suspect would lead the
same group of analysts to push it even
closer to midnight what did we learn not
that your read about it in the press but
what did you learn if you looked at
what's happening well there was an
extremely important article that
appeared in The Bulletin of Atomic
Scientists which is the main scientific
journal that deals with nuclear or other
strategic issues what it discussed was
the nuclear modernization programs that
were initiated by Obama and are being
carried forward next more under crumb
and it pointed out it's a technical
article but basically what it pointed
out is that these modernization programs
had already increased the kill capacity
the destructive capacity of the US
nuclear weapon systems web large factor
by maybe a factor of three enough they
said to completely wipe out the Russian
deterrent okay it's not that the
Russians don't know this Russia does not
have our sophisticated early warning
system satellite warning systems they're
much more primitive ones they don't get
much advanced warning of a alleged
attack there have been many close calls
in the past because of this well now
they're aware that the u.s.
modernization programs are able to
completely wipe out their deterrent
because we so expanded already our
destructive capacity by a huge factor
that would and as they point out in the
article this means that the system of
stability by which the world has been
kind of hanging by a thread pretty
slender thread it's being seriously
threatened means that in the event of
some rising tension there's plenty of
tensions at the Russian border not at
the Mexican border at the Russian border
plenty of them and plenty of
provocations they might just out of
desperation decide well we better launch
a preemptive strike or were gone we
don't have a deterrent that's what's
being developed it's another great
contribution of human intelligence to
develop means to make our own
destruction far more likely that's
what's been that's what we've learned in
the last couple months these should be
screaming headlines all over the place
just like the there should be headlines
about the Republican Party trying to
destroy the prospects for organized
human life that's what journalism would
be if it were concerned with bringing to
people the things that are significant
for people who live in a democratic
society who can make decisions about how
to deal with the problems they face in
their lives now almost nothing about it
it's not a secret you know it's not
classified you can find out about it
it's free country in that respect and
important respect should respect and
honor that but these are the things that
are happening right now and it means
that the sledgehammers that we've
constructed in our brilliance to
threaten our survival are getting far
more dangerous while the political
mechanisms that might lead to a sensible
reaction are being destroyed and we see
the impact in the rise of
anger contempt for institutions
irrational reactions kinds of things
that scapegoating you know things that
are pretty dangerous we've again
constructed a remarkable perfect storm
well and we have time for a few
questions maybe five or at the most six
questions and if you can keep them very
brief Ashley is coming to the mic to
organize we have more limited time than
we thought so we're going to take about
one or two questions if that's okay with
everyone thank you
hi um I was wondering as an aspiring
linguist do you believe that linguistics
can provide context to contemporary
political occurrences and if so how I
think linguistics can make a great many
contributions but in another domain it
can help us understand the unique human
capacity that is the fundamental
property that separates us from the rest
of the animal world our ability to do
things like we're doing right now where
does that come from that we're the only
animal that can do anything remotely
like this and it's the source of
creative activities if you look at the
evolutionary record the real outburst of
creative activity appears to be
associated with the emergence of
language and you can learn a lot about
these aspects of human nature and human
creativity and so on but as far as
analysis of the world political
situation is concerned frankly I don't
think anything is required but common
sense and a little bit of work
common sense open mind some work it's
not hidden it's all pretty much on the
surface of what we understand is pretty
much apparent to us if we take the
trouble to find out and I don't think
any specialized fields whether it's
linguistics or political science or
economics they can tell you something
but almost everything that's happening
of significance is pretty easy to
ascertain by a person who looks at the
world with an open critical mind and is
willing to search for things that are
not right in the front of you and that
are hidden on the sides but are
available
and final question hi
I actually was just wondering if you
felt that Abraham Lincoln was justified
in the suspension of habeas corpus
during the Civil War it's a it's not a
trivial question a lot was at stake but
my own feeling is that it was an act of
state that was not justified well no
thank you not only for this evening but
for your decades of commitment to
improving the human condition
thank you everyone
thank you all for coming once again the
signing line will form down this far I
also my right and wrap around the back
of the church so if you'd like to join
the signing line from the center aisle
or the aisle to my left you should make
your way toward the back of the church
thank you so much
[Music]
No yeah